we'll work on all of these things in the
meantime let's get you moving with your
most accurate weather now forecast
sherry's off today from the bowtie nate
home studio
we're looking at our camera now from the
red rock resort went on the west side of
town across to the east
definitely a lot of cloud cover not a
whole lot of wind we'll check the
radar here in just a moment but 41
degrees is the official temperature out
at mccarran we wanted to check the
temperatures in your neighborhoods
we have lots of ratings still in the
upper 30s so make sure you are dressed
properly if you're going out for a run
or jog or
walking the dog or whatever so there's
kyle cannon with a 22.
we have a live web camera from lee
cannon over on the other side
and there is a little bit of light snow
falling as they try to get the runs
ready for today remember you cannot just
spur the moment go up to lake canyon
okay some other temperatures around the
rest of southern nevada
how about the mid 40s for death valley
look at ely now dropping to
four degrees caliente you've dropped a
couple of degrees and
we're forecasting single digits for you
guys tonight 25
right now for cedar city so for the rest
of today we're looking for 55 for the
high after 53 yesterday
our current temperature is the low so
far this morning but check out the rain
that continues to fall over parts of
southern california and arizona
but we'll talk more about the snow
that's falling in the nation's
midsection we are focused on
a very windy new year's eve day on
thursday
okay now for your family and friends you
got a mix of rain snow and ice across
parts of kansas
otherwise that big snow from denver to
lincoln nebraska is heading up to
minneapolis
your seven-day forecast now for the rest
of 2020 after 55 today
more clouds and maybe a little bit of
breeziness tomorrow but the wind really
picks up out of the north on new year's
eve day upwards of 30 miles an hour
could be very windy for those folks
welcoming in the new year
january 1 the daytime high 54.